it might seem intuitive that we can
predict tomorrow's weather pretty well,
but not whether it will rain on Tuesday
three weeks from now.
But we didn't always think that way about the weather.
Our understanding of the atmosphere and
its patterns was forever changed by the
contributions of two exceptional pioneers:
MIT professors Jule Charney and
Edward Lorenz.
Heralds of the modern era
of meteorology, Charney and Lorenz - each
in his own way - left an indelible mark on
MIT - and the world.
At the height of the
Second World War, an unprecedented demand
for weather forecasting expertise fueled
a nationwide effort to train a
generation of meteorologists. Among the
young recruits was UCLA graduate student
Jule Gregory Charney, who had discovered
a talent for mathematics at an early age.
Anticipating the United States' entry
into World War II, and encouraged by
Caltech professor Theodore von Kármán, he
signed up for a course in meteorology in
1940, seeing an opportunity to excel.
Meanwhile, on the other side of the country at MIT,
an aviation cadet and
mathematics graduate named Edward Norton Lorenz
began his own training in 1942 in
the Department of Meteorology, Course 19,
marking the beginning of a
lifelong connection to the Institute.
When the war ended, Lorenz returned to
MIT to complete his Master's Degree and
PhD in meteorology. After graduating in
1948, he stayed on as a research
scientist working with the Victor Starr
on the general circulation of the
atmosphere. After publishing a landmark
paper on atmospheric energy cycles
called "Available Potential Energy and
the Maintenance of the General
Circulation," Lorenz joined the faculty in
1955. His advisor, Victor Starr, had been
recruited by Henry Houghton, Head of MIT's Department of Meteorology from
1942 to 1969. During his tenure, Houghton
transformed the department into a
cutting-edge research powerhouse. He
founded the training program attended by
Lorenz during the war - which grew the
department more than tenfold - and oversaw
the development of weather radar. Later,
in a prescient move, he nurtured MIT's
growing oceanography program, with help
from the Woods Hole Oceanographic
Institution, and saw it integrated with
atmospheric research. Houghton's vision
and guidance laid a far-reaching
foundation for scientific advance that
would shape the meteorological world for
decades to come.
While Lorentz was beginning his career
in meteorological research at MIT, Jule
Charney was beginning to embark on a new
adventure of his own. Following the war,
Charney had returned to UCLA to complete
his doctorate in 1946. His PhD thesis,
"Dynamics of Long Waves in a Baroclinic
Westerly Current," was
groundbreaking work, which established
the mechanism for the emergence and
evolution of weather systems, and what
sets their structure size and growth
rate. This was an early example of
Charney's aptitude for applying
mathematics to understanding physical
processes.
Over the next two years, working first as a
research scientist at the University of
Chicago with Carl Gustav Rossby - who
founded the first meteorology program at
MIT in 1928 - and then as a National
Research
Council fellow studying in Oslo, Charney
developed his quasi-geostrophic
equations, which laid the foundation for
modern dynamical meteorology and
oceanography. These equations not only
allowed large-scale motions of the
atmosphere to be analyzed without being
overshadowed by noisy effects at smaller
scales; they could also be integrated
forward in time to predict the weather.
In 1948, Charney took up an appointment
at Princeton University's Institute for
Advanced Study to work with
mathematician John von Neumann and
future MIT meteorology professor Norman
Phillips on the earliest numerical
weather prediction models. Their first
calculations were run on the ENIAC
computer and published in 1950, and in
the years that followed, Charney's
theoretical meteorology group
demonstrated that the quasi-geostrophic
equations were able to reproduce
important aspects of the general
circulation, and even predict the
formation of cyclones. This resounding
success
won widespread acceptance in the
meteorological community for numerical
weather prediction. The equations also
became the theoretical foundation of
modern dynamical meteorology and
oceanography, permeating every aspect of
the field.
Building on this momentum, Charney helped
to establish the Joint Numerical Weather
Prediction Unit in 1954, a collaboration
between the U.S. Weather Bureau, Air
Force, and Navy.
A year later, he had a hand in starting
up the General Circulation Research
Section of the Weather Bureau, and while
this group would eventually become
NOAA's Geophysical Fluid Dynamics
Laboratory and relocate to Princeton,
Charney was already considering a move
to MIT.
During an interview, then Provost and
Vice President Julius Stratton asked
Charney what could be done to improve
the Meteorology Department. Having always
been impressed by Ed Lorenz - then still a
research scientist - Charney replied that
the first thing to do would be to
promote Lorenz and his adviser Victor
Starr. He also reached out to recruit his
Princeton colleague, Norman Phillips.
Lorenz and Phillips were duly offered
faculty positions and Charney likewise
joined MIT to direct the Atmospheric and
Ocean Dynamics Project in 1956.
Charismatic and open-minded, Charney had
a knack for bringing people together. He
quickly established an informal seminar
series on geophysical fluid dynamics, a
tradition that would continue for 22
years,
attracting experts from around New
England in the fields of meteorology,
oceanography, geophysics, and applied
mathematics. During his 25 years at MIT,
Charney mentored countless students and
made profound lasting impacts on the
field through groundbreaking research on
such diverse topics as the stability of
atmospheric and oceanic flows, the
formation and evolution of weather
systems and hurricanes, oceanic boundary
currents, how large-scale planetary waves
extend up into the stratosphere, the
formation of deserts, and how westerly
winds can flip between banded and wavy
patterns. He also continued to play a
role in the establishment of critical
weather-related initiatives, including
the Global Atmospheric Research Program,
an observational effort improving
numerical weather prediction. One of
Charney's last contributions was a
pioneering study conducted for the
National Academy of Sciences. The 1979
Charney Report was one of the earliest
modern scientific assessments of global
warming. He estimated that a sustained
doubling of atmospheric CO2 would lead
to a surface temperature increase of
between 1.5 and 4.5 degrees centigrade, a
range that has been vigorously debated
and has stood the test of time. Though
Charney and Lorenz shared a similar
background in mathematics and a mutual
admiration for one another, the two never
worked together directly during their
time at MIT. Nevertheless, their research
interests intersected and the
development of numerical weather
prediction facilitated by Charney's
equations carried Lorentz's research
into atmospheric dynamics forward.
In 1967, he published "The Nature and
Theory of the General Circulation of the
Atmosphere," a treatise now considered a
classic work of scientific literature. By
that time, however, a new exciting
research direction had begun to occupy
Lorenz's attention. In 1963, after
noticing that very slightly different
initial conditions - due to roundoff
errors generated by his LGP-30 computer -
resulted in rapidly diverging solutions,
Lorenz published a landmark article on
chaos theory, the idea that nonlinear
systems such as weather are practically
unpredictable,
despite their deterministic evolution.
The Lorenz system, three differential
equations that relate the motions of a
fluid layer warmed from below and cooled
from above, is one of the fundamental
systems studied in chaos theory. These
simple equations revealed startling
behavior, which led Lorenz to an
important insight. Though the chaotic
solutions never repeat, they nevertheless
tend to look very similar, even when
starting from a range of initial
conditions. Run many times, the solutions
trace out a previously unknown
mathematical object that Lorenz termed a
"strange attractor." This fractal set of
solutions introduced new tools to
analyze nonlinear chaotic systems,
helping to answer questions like why
some weather pattern geometries are
common while others seem never to occur.
Continuing his study of predictability,
Lorenz demonstrated in 1969 that the
nonlinear interaction among motions of
many different scales could lead to loss
of predictability even when the model is
perfect and the initial errors are
vanishingly small.
This
theory was popularized as "the butterfly
effect," the idea that small changes can
have large consequences.
Lorenz's discovery not only
revolutionized the understanding of
fluid turbulence and weather, but also
led to advances in mathematics, the
natural sciences, and engineering. Lorenz
was a vital member of MIT for over 60
years, serving as the Head of Meteorology
from 1977 to 1981. Much beloved as an
instructor and mentor, he was repeatedly
honored as "Best Teacher of the Year," by
MIT graduate students, and he continued
to conduct research and give lectures
well after becoming a Professor Emeritus
in 1987. He passed away on April 16th,
2008, and three years later, MIT created
the Lorenz Center in his honor,
dedicated to furthering the basic
understanding of climate science. By
comparison, Jule Charney's tenure at
MIT was relatively brief. After a fierce
battle with cancer, he died on June 16th,
1981, just two years after publishing his
pioneering report on the connection
between carbon dioxide and climate. Even
so, his impact on MIT and around the
world stands shoulder-to-shoulder with
that of his colleague and friend, Ed Lorenz.
Born 100 years ago,
both men fundamentally reshaped the
science of meteorology during their
lifetimes.
Charney saw the dawn of numerical
weather prediction and its widespread
influence on nearly every aspect of
atmospheric and oceanographic research.
Lorenz shifted our basic conception of
weather and climate from deterministic
phenomena to chaos, and this insight
suggested new ways to examine nonlinear
chaotic systems, an impact that spread
outward from meteorology to transform a
host of other disciplines. But perhaps
their most enduring legacy is the
community of people trained, taught, and
inspired by Jule Charney and Ed Lorenz.
"What I discovered after moving to MIT
was that I what I did enjoy mostly was
working more individually with graduate students on thesis research and research problems, because I find
that my own work is greatly enhanced and
becomes much more enjoyable
when I can discuss it with other people. Today, the study of
atmospheric science continues at MIT in
the wider context of EAPS, the Department
of Earth, Atmospheric, and Planetary
Sciences, formed in 1983 from the merger
of Meteorology and Earth Sciences. Now,
100 years later, the Program in
Atmospheres, Oceans, and Climate, within
EAPS, celebrates and honors the lives
of Charney and Lorenz, as their students
and their students' students continue to
walk in their footsteps, exploring the
myriad reverberations of the work they
set in motion.